Hi everyone, and welcome to
today's Google Developers Live
for Google Drive.
Today I'm going to talk about a
very, very small change that
was made to Auth in
Google Drive.
And it's just one little check
box in our SDK settings.
But it actually has really big
implications for how you
develop your application.
So I want to switch over to
our SDK settings here.
This is the APIs console.
And if you've built a Drive
app that does open with or
create from the Drive UI, you've
been in here before and
you're familiar with it.
But one thing that changed
probably about a month back is
this Authentications section.
Before, this little check box
that says, "Automatically
initiate the OAuth to flow"
was not present, and this
section was always enabled
for applications.
What this did is when a user
clicked Open With or clicked
on a file or clicked Create in
the Drive menu, Drive would
automatically initiate the OAuth
flow on behalf of your
application.
It did some really good
things as a result.
It solved one really important
problem for developers, which
is handling multiple
user accounts.
Since we already knew which
user was logged in, which
Drive account it was, we were
able to automatically route
that Auth flow for
the correct user.
So you didn't have to
worry about that.
But it did have some negative
side effects, too.
So one of them was, it's
pretty tedious to
configure all this.
There's a little bit
of duplication.
You can see here we have
to copy our client ID.
This is from the API
access section.
We needed to list all the scopes
that our app used.
By default, it included
the drive.file.scope.
But if you needed access to the
user's profile or their
email address, for example, you
had to copy these in here.
But you also needed to list
these in your code as well,
because most apps had use cases
where they needed to
initiate the OAuth
flow themselves.
So you just had a lot
of copying and
pasting back and forth.
And every time you added a new
scope, you wanted to make sure
that you kept these in sync.
There were also some other
complications with the
Redirect URI, specifically
again some duplicate
configuration.
Because Drive was initiating the
flow, it was setting the
redirect URIs to your Open URL,
or if you had Create, you
had a Create URL.
And for example, if you wanted
to have a separate action for
these two different events, we
now had two different redirect
URIs that we could
possibly receive.
And hey, look at that.
An unexpected error.
That is really unexpected.
So anyway, you had these two
different redirect URIs.
You would also have to copy
those into the API access and
register them.
And then in your code, of
course, you would need to have
those configured and then switch
depending on which one.
It made handling OAuth in
Drive a little bit more
tedious and error prone than
it really needed to be.
So what changed?
Basically, what we added is an
option to disable this for
applications.
And by default for new
applications, Drive-initiated
OAuth is disabled.
What this means is that your
application, if you're writing
a new Drive app, you are in
complete control over how
OAuth works within
your application.
I did mention earlier that the
previous mechanism had solved
one important problem,
which is multi-login.
To help you handle that now
when you're initiating the
flow yourself, we added a new
parameter into the JSON state
parameter that Drive
gives you.
And it's obviously
called User ID.
And this user ID can then be
used by your application to
give us a hint when we prompt
the user for authorization
which account we should be
authorizing with if they
happen to be logged in with
multiple accounts.
One word of warning.
This User ID is not the user's
regular user ID.
For privacy reasons, it's
obfuscated differently than we
would obfuscate other user IDs,
because at the point when
we're giving this to your
application, the user may not
have approved your app.
They may have just installed
through the Chrome Web Store,
which doesn't have the same
set of approvals that you
would have on the
OAuth screen.
So until the user has fully
consented to giving
information to your application,
what you receive
about who the user is
is an opaque ID.
It's obfuscated differently than
other IDs that you may
see for that user in the Drive
API or in, say, the user
profile or Google+ APIs, so you
can't really use that as a
way to correlate
user activity.
But you can use it, and you
should use it, as a hint when
initiating the OAuth flow so
that the correct account is
used and authorized for
your application.
So why did we make
these changes?
Well, one was, I mentioned
earlier the previous mechanism
was just very tedious, a lot of
duplicate configuration, a
lot of things that you can get
wrong when setting up your
application.
But the bigger implication was
it was actually very difficult
to create a Drive application
that was pure client-side.
So for example, if you wanted to
do a pure JavaScript client
application, or doing a
Chrome-packaged app, because
we were always requesting--
always initiating an OAuth flow
that was designed for
server-based web applications
and included things like
offline access, it just made it
very difficult to do a pure
client-side.
You always had to have that
little bit of server code
running in order to handle
this login case.
It wasn't too bad, but now you
can actually use a JavaScript
client library, for example,
and keep the authorization
flow completely within
the web browser.
The other thing is it gives
you a little bit more
flexibility in terms of what
you need from OAuth.
For example, with the previous
mechanism, because it was
always using the drive.file
scope, it pretty much forced
you into using that scope
if you had an app.
You could, of course, always
add an additional scope to
get, say, the full Drive
access if your
application needed it.
But then you would have
a very confusing
authorization dialogue.
And while we certainly encourage
everyone to use the
narrowest scope possible for
their application, and the
drive.file one is definitely
preferred, there are certain
applications that really have a
very compelling use case and
a justified use for having the
full scope for Drive while
still appearing in the Drive
Create menu and being able to
open files from the UI.
So if you do fall into that
category, you now have the
option of initiating the OAuth
request using just the Drive
scope and avoiding having
duplicate text or conflicting
text in the OAuth dialogue,
which potentially could
confuse users.
So one of things that
I'm actually
really curious to do--
for those who have been through
our documentation and
our samples, you know we have
a JavaScript quick start.
We don't yet have a JavaScript
version of the text editor
sample that we have for
most other languages.
That is something that
we would like to do.
Hopefully we'll have that out
soon so that you can actually
see how to build a pure
client-side application and
take advantage of this change
in how we open applications.
But there are some other things
that I think would be
interesting challenges for
people to try, things that I
want to try myself.
I'm really hoping that
somebody's going to beat me to
it in the community and maybe
can post in the Google+
community about whether or not
it was successful or learned.
But really, the two things that
I'm curious to see how
they would work with Drive
apps, one is building a
Chrome-packaged app.
Now that we can actually build
Drive applications that are
completely client-side, it
should be possible to build a
packaged app that works with the
Drive APIs that integrates
with the UI and runs
without a server.
And then the other thing is
I know there are some new
experimental APIs in Chrome
for identity.
Of course, we have the ability
in the JavaScript client
library to do authorization.
It would be just really curious
to see if people are
successful in using the identity
APIs in Chrome as an
alternative, particularly
when combined with
the packaged app.
So interesting things to do.
Maybe when we do to the
JavaScript version of our text
editor, that's something that
we can look at trying.
But if somebody out there is
really curious and wants to
try it, I'd love to hear the
results of that, whether or
not you're successful.
That's really the change.
I just want to give a couple
other tips related to OAuth.
And this is regardless of how
you're doing it, whether or
not it's client side or you're
still using the server flows.
Just remember that with this
change, what your app is doing
is really just plain OAuth 2
that you would use for any web
application, whether or not it
was for Drive or using any of
our other APIs, like Google+
or Calendar or Contacts.
It doesn't really matter.
It is important, though,
particularly in the case of
Drive, that when you are given
a user ID hint when a user
initiates an action from Drive
that you include this in your
authorization request.
And this should work for both
the JavaScript client in the
configuration--
you can just give it user_ID
and then the value.
Similarly for all of the client
libraries, they all
allow this in the
OAuth request.
If you happen to be constructing
the URL by hand,
the query parameter that you
would include in the request
is user_ID.
And then you would set that to
the value that you get in the
state parameter.
This is really important.
If you don't do this, what could
happen is a user would
attempt to open a file.
When they do the approval
dialogue, depending on which
account they were using in
Drive and which is their
default, or depending on just
what they select in the
account chooser, they may
pick the wrong account.
And what would happen is you
would end up getting
authorization for an account
that is different than the
owner of the file that the user
is trying to act upon.
So what would happen is
you would authorize.
Things would look great.
But as soon as you try to read
that file, you're going to get
an error saying that you
don't have access.
That would just be really
confusing for the user.
You'd have to handle that, kind
of back out, retry the
authorization, and hope that
they picked the right user
account again.
It's just not a good
user experience.
But if we can give you the
user ID and you have it,
include it in the request, and
it will ensure that the user
gets a really nice,
smooth experience.
You can do some optimizations,
depending on
how your app is done.
So for example, it's quite
common for a user to launch an
application from Drive for an
app that they're already
logged into.
So if you don't want to blindly
check and reauthorize
every time, what you could do is
you can detect if the user
has an active session, check to
see if it's the same user--
because it is possible if
they're logged in with
multiple accounts that they may
have switched accounts in
between that period of time.
But you can use the user ID
from the state parameter
against a saved value.
If they're the same, there's
really no need to reauthorize
in that case.
And so you can save a redirect
or save those two to three
seconds that it takes to
actually do the authorization,
and then just let the
user in right away.
If it's a different user or
you don't have an active
session, then of course you do
want to go through the full
authorization flow and make
sure they have an updated
access token.
For JavaScript, if you're
building a client-side
application, you can do
this type of check.
There is what we call immediate
mode, which is a way
that you can check to see if
the user has previously
authorized your application
and get an
updated access token.
You should always do
this first for
the JavaScript client.
What this allows you to do
is that if the user has
previously authorized your
application, we don't want to
show an approval prompt.
We really just want
to give you an
access token right away.
Immediate mode allows your
application to do that check
but do it in a way that is
transparent to the users, so
actually do a hidden iframe with
post message, handle that
communication.
And then you just get
back a status.
You either get back
a successful
authorization or a failure.
And if it's a failure, then
you want to go through the
normal authorization flow.
And when you do the normal
authorization, you'll get a
popup and then the full UI for
authorizing your application.
What this immediate mode does,
besides giving a quick way to
do it, is in the case that the
user is authorized, it's just
a nicer experience, because it
avoids flashing a popup.
Even though it's only there for
half a second or a second,
it's still something that you
want to avoid just to keep
your UI nice and clean.
Other than that, just remember
with OAuth in general, whether
or not you're talking to our
APIs or any other provider,
they do want to keep your
keys and secrets
protected, same as tokens.
Treat these like passwords.
It's a lot easier to reset
tokens or reset your
credentials if they happen
to be compromised.
But obviously, you want to avoid
ever having credentials
compromised in first place,
because it is disruptive, both
to you as a developer and to
your users if they have to
reauthorize access to
your application.
So treat these as sensitive
materials, as you would for
any other credential that you
would store in your system.
Other than that, I think
that's really about it.
I do know there are a couple
issues with the JavaScript
client related to multi-login.
I know there's some issues in
Stack Overflow related to
this, and in the Issue Tracker
on the client API.
It should, however, still work
with the user ID parameter.
So basically, the issue that I'm
referring to is by default
when you do an OAuth request
with the JavaScript client, if
the user is logged in with
multiple accounts, it's always
going to default to
the first user.
However, if you do give it to
the user ID parameter, it
should pick the correct
user regardless.
Just at the moment, there's
really no way to force the
account chooser if you want
to make it an interactive
experience.
That is something that we're
aware of, hopefully something
that will be fixed
not too long.
But for the purposes of a Drive
app, you should be able
to do things correctly and
have a good experience.
And again, hopefully, probably
in the next week or two, maybe
a little bit longer, we'll have
an updated text editor
sample that shows how to
do this in JavaScript.
And then from there, maybe we'll
try some of these other
experiments with packaged
apps and so on.
Again, I would love to see
somebody from the community
try these things and give us
your feedback as to what works
and what doesn't and if there's
things that we could
do to make it easier.
Other than that, that's
all I have on this.
Again, always check back
in the documentation.
We'll try to keep
it up to date.
Look for refreshes of a
lot of our samples.
In the future there are some
other OAuth-related changes
that we made, things like the
install scope which we've
talked about back before the
holidays, things that just
make it a lot easier for you as
a developer to get your app
up and running without
having to go
through a lot of overhead.
So in the near future, we're
going to update all those
examples, clean up all the
details that we used to have
in there about working with the
Chrome Web Store, switch
over to using the install
scope for Auth, and just
generally make it a much easier
experience for you as a
developer to get started
with these APIs.
So that's all for today.
I'm not sure what our next
topic is going to be, but
check back on the Google
Developers Live site.
We'll be back on Friday.
Our new normal times are, I
believe, Tuesdays and Fridays.
And look for either Ali or
Claudio to be here next time.
So thank you, everyone.
And we'll probably see
you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]